ابراهيم يعني على ما يبدو الاصابع
الاسرائيليه تشير الى
مسؤوليه قد يتحملها حزب الله في هذه
العمليه التي وصفت بالخطيره هل وردت اي
ردود افعال وماذا تقول الروايه اللبنانيه
حيث
في الواقع ايمان ليس هنالك اي رد فعل من
حزب الله ولكن من خلال تواصلي مع مصادر
متابعه وعليمه بكيفيه تعامل ومقاربه حزب
الله لهكذا ملفات يمكن الحديث عن ثلاث
ملاحظات وخلاصه الملاحظه الاولى التي يتم
التعامل معها هنا في بيروت ويقاربها حزب
الله هي ان الاتهام الاسرائيلي ترك الباب
مواربا عندما قال بانه يفحص امكانيه ان
يكون حزب الله ضالعا في هذه العمليه
وبالتالي هو لن يقدم في روايته كلاما
جازما عن طلوع حزب الله وبالتالي لن يقوم
الحزب حاليا بتقديم اي رد على هذه
الادعاءات الاسرائيليه وفق هذه المصادر
بانتظار ان يكون هنالك كلمه فصل من الجانب
الاسرائيلي توضح فعلا هل ان ما يجري
الحديث عنه هنالك اتهام واضح ومباشر لحزب
الله هذه الملاحظه الاولى الملاحظه
الثانيه ترتبط بكيفيه مقاربه حزب الله
لهذه العمليات العسكريه بطبيعتها حزب الله
كان قد اعلن ساب على لسان امينه العام عام
2019 بعدما اعلنت اسرائيل عن اكتشاف
مجموعه من الانفاق بين لبنان واسرائيل
واعلنت حينها ضمن عمليه درع الشمال عن
تدمير هذه الانفاق اعلن الاميره العام
لحزب الله حينها بان حزمه لن يقوم بالدخول
الى هذه الاراضي المحتله الا اذا قامت
اسرائيل بعمليه مهاجمه الاراضي اللبنانيه
وبالتالي هو اكد وجود كل تلك انفاق
العسكريه المتواجده على الحدود ولكنه
وصفها بانها انفاق دفاعيه الى ان يحين
موعد تنفيذ عمليه الجليل وفق توصيفه وهي
عمليه يدخل من خلالها المقاتلون الى عمق
اراضي الجليل اذا ما قامت اسرائيل بمهاجمه
لبنان وهذا ما لا يندرج حاليا اما
الملاحظه الثالثه فهي ترتبط بمقاربه حزب
الله ايضا لموضوع الحدود هنالك حديث عن ان
الحدود يمكن ان يتسلل منها بعض الاشخاص
كما حصل عام 2002 عندما قام مقاتلان من
الجهاد الاسلامي بالتوغل داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه وحينها نفذوا عمليه
المستوطنات شلونهم ادت الى مقتل عدد من
الاسرائيليين وهنا المصادر تدلل على ان
العمليه وطريقه الحديث عنها اسرائيليا بان
هنالك متسلل يدخل الى عمق سبعين كيلو مترا
يضع عبوه ليستهدف مستوطن ومن بعدها ينسحب
الى الحدود اللبنانيه ويتم تصفيته فان هذا
السيناريو وهذه اليه اعتماد هكذا عمليه لا
يقوم بها حزب الله وبالتالي هذه الملاحظات
الثلاث هي ما يؤدي الى خلاصه باتت شائعه
اليوم ضمن حلقه ضيقه وقريبه من حزب الله
بان نتنياهو انما عندما يعلن عن هذا الامر
هو يسعى الى قذف كل ما يتعرض له وتصدير
ازمته الى الخارج بمعنى ان الازمه
الداخليه الاسرائيليه تدفع نتنياهو الى
التعلق باي تفصيل امني من هنا او هناك
ورميه على حزب الله وبالتالي دفع كل هذا
الامر باتجاه الخارج من خلال تصعيد على
مستوى الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان وبالتالي
هنا الترقب على هذا المست في لبنان لان
الحديث يدور بان كل هذه الروايه هي مصدر
تشكيك على المستوى اللبنانيه على الاقل في
اتهام حزب الله مباشره بانه يقف وراءه
هكذا عمليه لانه طبيعه العمليات التي
ينفذها لا يمكن ان تكون ضمن هذا السياق
انما تاخذ سياقات مختلفه واساليب عملياته
عسكريه مختلفه وبالتالي التجديد هنا على
ان نتنياهو يحاول تصدير ازمته الداخليه
الى لبنان شكرا لك مازن ابراهيم مدير مكتب
الجزيره كنت معنا من الناقوره على الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه